wir sprechen über eine attacke auf einen
rabbiner mitten in berlin weil er jude
ist passiert ist genau das vor 24
stunden an einer u-bahn-haltestelle in
berlin-tempelhof ariel killzone rabbiner
der jüdischen gemeinde in potsdam hat
karte telefoniert war unterwegs mit
seinem 13 jahre alten sohn levi wollte
zu einem arztbesuch nach berlin direkt
in die hauptstadt und ist dann
attackiert worden beschimpft worden der
angreifer hat immer wieder jude jude
geschrieben geschrien und hat ihn
bedroht den rabbiner von potsdam jetzt
sind wir mit ihm verbunden mit ariel
carson dem landesrabbiner der jüdischen
gemeinde in potsdam
danke dass sie sich die zeit nehmen für
das gespräch mit uns berichten sie uns
einmal wie haben sie diesen
schrecklichen angriff erlebt
haben sie gesetze unterwegs jetzt mal
gesungen sowohl arzt besucht
und plötzlich habe er telefoniert ich
sage ich und schafft einen gelähmt und
hebräisch gesprochen und wir warten beim
u 6 und hier raus gegangen und ich hatte
nicht so mir sogleich verstanden was
passiert weil jemand vor mir angreifen
mir
schulter und geschreie wasser ag g j
weil ich gesagt ich war jemand telefon
hatte ich hörte wollte jude ja und
danach mein sohn hat mir gesagt dass er
geschichte geschrieben
scheiße schmutzige judith also
wir waren schockiert heute könnte keine
sachen tun und
ein bisschen muss man merkt ihnen genau
diese schock noch anders und hat sie das
überrascht haben sie ähnliche vorfälle
auch schon selber erlebt von ihren
freunden gehört aus ihrer gemeinde
gehört
ich habe das schon überlebte mal in
berlin drei jahre
ich habe nie gemeldet weil ich wusste
nicht was soll er tun ich wusste nicht
was gut man in diesen fällen und auch
das wahre weihnacht allem bei nacht das
war und vier
russen kommen bestimmt die wirte und ich
wusste nicht was überlegt und diese frei
und auch es war keine kameras und es war
nach und
und den kosten die frau soll auf touren
und danach nicht haben gesagt du soleil
ist ein anruf dieses mal das passiert
schon und ich habe gesehen auch das gibt
es doch noch kann mir da noch die prüfe
diese menschen schnell werden finden
hat irgendjemand
reagiert ihnen geholfen es hat ihnen
irgendjemand und auch ihren sohn ihr
kind beide standen in dieser situation
ist es warten keine war ihm ein somit
eine frau
nicht reagiert ich habe nun gesehen die
frauen um
sie ist nichts
passiert ist das ja nicht irgendwann
nachts sondern eben am hellichten tag im
berliner bezirk tempelhof dort an der u6
haltestelle wie sie es gerade gesagt
haben was war das für ein typ der dort
sie beschimpft hat und der sie
attackiert hat
mit seiner schulter an schulter und
bestimmte worte
beschreiben den typen der wird ja jetzt
gesucht nachdem wird gefahren und sie
haben gerade gesagt sie hoffen dass er
möglichst schnell gestellt wird wie
würden sie die mir schreiben
möchte immer fotografien weil mein sohn
hat mir gesagt er ist aggressiv braucht
man nicht nur am besten das nicht so
einfach gegangen weil auch gewandelt zu
was sagen sie ihrem sohn sicherlich
sprechen sie auch in der familie über
diesen schrecklichen vorfall
was sagen sie ihrem sohn levi s 13 jahre
als sagen sie ihm jetzt in deutschland
hier in berlin geht lieber nicht mit
einer kippa raus macht das lieber nicht
wie besprechen sie das in der folge
fühlen sie sich damit ich sagen erster
geht nichts somit gibt ball geht mit
und auch er
[Musik]
sehe sich hier und auch mein frau viele
mal gesagt mir und sonne einmal gesagt
sie soll den keeper mit cap mit käppi
gehen mit
großem
und jederzeit sich hat so gesagt und sie
hat mit sorge auch man fahre ich nach
potsdam gebiet machen weil dort im bus
damit haben kein sicherheit im auge und
auch vorher ich war alles
landesregierung vor allem und sie wissen
was passiert im rhein ich war zwei
jahren in halle
gefahren und nichts passiert und
plötzlich passiert ich war schon jetzt
sagen ja aber lustig passiert und auch
die situation jetzt auch in potsdam
jetzt kein sicherheit und auch kann
passiert und alles und auch was kann man
sehen auch in berlin was passiert das
eher an juden jahren
ich nur bittet dass dieser mensch werden
finden was und gibt es kein wir das auch
und auch ebit um sich in meine gemeinde
das ist ja noch lang das mindeste das
ist ehrlich gesagt das mindeste noch
eine frage zum schluss was sagen sie der
regierende bürgermeisterin von berlin
die ja weiß weil es gab ganz viele
solcher vorfälle sei es in kreuzberg in
neukölln oder jetzt eben im bezirk
tempelhof wenn man wie sie das gerade
schildern nicht sicher sein kann als
jude dass man auf der straße nicht
beschimpft bespuckt beleidigt oder
angegriffen wird michelle und ich raffe
stellen das so gesagt
keiner sollte es nie gesehen dass das
rad nicht verstanden ihnen sind
eine traurige erkenntnis eine erkenntnis
die man verstehen kann und trotzdem
traurig zu hören dass sich jüdinnen und
juden die hier in deutschland in berlin
in der hauptstadt nicht sicher fühlen
sich nicht zu erkennen geben können als
juden habitus und vielen herzlichen dank
ihnen für ihre schilderungen
[Musik]